white flag expecting a me oh my gosh why
did you want to showcase your journey
going into motherhood well honestly I
think people relate to me and you know
pregnancy you were supposed to make it
look easy and I I just like really
reject that in the HBO max three part
donkey series expecting Amy the 39 year
old comic shows her entire pregnancy
journey from the test I found out two
days ago to her excruciating battle with
hyperemesis gravidarum a pregnancy
disorder that left her violently ill
almost the entire nine months Chris had
to take me to the ER because I couldn't
keep anything down but the scariest
moment for Amy happened during an
ultrasound when doctors discovered a
possible abnormality with genes kidney
one of the hardest moments I think of my
whole pregnancy was was when the doctor
asked us to turn the camera off the
whole time they were they thought
something's wrong his kidneys but they
do an ultrasound they just go skewed
knees are fine he's totally healthy and
and we're like you know so grateful the
reviews are in and now that 14 month
olds approves you guys have created the
cutest kid him reading the reviews from
expected and I was like dang isatis it's
the first murder it's a paper when they
eat it and so that's he reads the paper
what can you say
Amy's willingness to be so candid has
also led to a new partnership
I wanted to partner with Tampax you take
the shame and all the myths away from
women's periods
amy is also hoping to lift the stigma of
IVF in February she revealed she had
begun the grueling process of freezing
an embryo in hopes of giving gene a
sibling we're gonna put trying to
increase our family on hold like a
pandemic does it just to me doesn't feel
like the time that I want to be
thrusting myself in the medical
environment if we can avoid it
[Music]